how's this for a deal tell me and I'll
kill you quickly instead of slowly
what's so great about Regina is that her
evolution to me has been the most
significant of any characters what is it
like to look back on that I think she's
still you know trying to be that hero
she's still trying to do the right thing
but just a matter of time before
something happens and maybe she'll turn
back to being able again but who knows I
think her journey is a very unique one
it's been a joy playing all these
different versions of her from being
this Evil Queen to being the old hag yes
I was the old hag people didn't know
that love your relationship with Regina
on the show so much what do you think it
is about this outlaw Queen couple that's
so special and that draws fans in both
sort of damaged people that have got a
dodgy past they've got darkness in their
past and I think there's something about
them the the sort of redemption that
there's this hope I think people really
kind of root for them and it's it's a
lovely thing to be a part of when you
see it on-screen I think you can tell
when people get along and you can tell
when they don't I think that chemistry
kind of comes through and learn and I
just kind of hit it off from day one so
she's just been a an absolute joy love
him to bits he's just a sweetheart and
just so much fun to work with and and
it's really beautiful to see Regina in
love and and that was all that's really
what she always wanted was love family
and love and now she has actually bring
it Carini
indeed I will we've got to talk about
the wickedness that is Zelena yes she's
coming back she's got to be coming back
you can't vanish that girl away
I just won't die sorry you can't get rid
of me this whole for the season is so
good that just the whole world that
we're in being in the underworld and
people's unfinished business and people
coming back I think the fans are gonna
love it I really do not too many
characters on TV can say that they have
let's see if I can get this right slept
with their sister's boyfriend while
disguise as said boyfriend's ex-wife
this has been great but ah does it feel
knowing that a show like once upon a
time can let you have such twisted fun
random episodes like that unbelievable
you're the first person to say it
congratulations
you completely nailed there that was
amazing I don't honestly don't think I
could repeat of what you just said but
yes that happens that happened in the
world of once upon a time absolutely
bonkers but if someone's gonna do it
I'll do it and as a result we now have a
sweet little green bean who does not
have a name yet hood are we gonna get
that name well I think so I don't know
what it is yet but we must name her at
some point
maybe I'll name her after you little
baby Leone I love that I like it